نظرًا لأن الأطباء والممرضات من المحافظين طالبوا بإلحاح للحصول على الإمدادات من المخزون الفيدرالي للحماية من أقنعة فيروس كورونا القاتلة ، فليس لديهم المعدات المناسبة التي يدخلونها إلى تلك الغرف مع الخوف من أننا بحاجة إلى هذه الموارد الآن فجأة قسم غير معروف للصحة والإنسان كانت خدمات المخزون الوطني الاستراتيجي في المقدمة ولكن لم يكن هناك ما يكفي تقريبًا لتسليح الأمة بأكملها لمحاربة جائحة فيروس كورونا ، كانت العديد من الولايات غير مستعدة تمامًا لهذا نحن لسنا كاتب أوامر كان ترامب بطيئًا في استخدامه قانون الإنتاج الدفاعي لدفع القطاع الخاص إلى زيادة الإنتاج وانتهى الأمر بالدول في حرب مزايدة دولية على الإمدادات الطبية ، نحن جميعًا نتنافس ضد بعضنا البعض ، ولا ينبغي أن تكون الدول التي تعرف الغرب المتوحش قتالًا أو هذا عندما ننتقل إلى المخزن للإغاثة السريعة التي كانت مخزنة في المخزن ، فإن الحكام الفيدراليين في حالة من الفوضى هنا في إلينوي ، ربما تلقينا 10 ٪ مما نحتاجه  ولذا
فقد أعادوا الأمر إلى الولايات
وقالوا جيدًا أنكم يا رفاق موجودون في ولاياتكم
الأخرى ، وتقولون إنهم تلقوا
إمدادات حيوية انتهت صلاحيتها متدهورة
أو معطلة.
أقل مما كانوا يأملون ، لكن اقتباس كل ولاية
حصل على نصيبه العادل
عمومًا ، بدا الرد الفيدرالي
غريبًا جاريد كوشنر ،
صهر الرئيس ، وتم إحضار مستشار كبير
للمساعدة في إدارة تحديات سلسلة التوريد ،
لكن جدلًا آخر
نشأ عندما ادعى المخزون
كان مخصصًا للحكومة الفيدرالية وليس
للولايات التي تتناقض بشكل مباشر مع
الموقع الإلكتروني حول
المخزون ، كان من
المفترض أن يكون المخزون الفيدرالي هو مخزوننا ، وليس من
المفترض أن يكون مخزونًا تابعًا للدولة في اليوم
التالي لإبداء كوشنر بتلك الملاحظات
، تم تغيير موقع الحكومة على الإنترنت  من
بيان مهمة طويل يقول إنه يتدخل
في حالة طوارئ صحية عامة شديدة
بما يكفي للتسبب في نفاد الإمدادات المحلية
إلى بيان أقصر يقول أنه
يمكن استخدام الإمدادات كمخزن مؤقت مؤقت قصير الأجل
، ولم يكن هناك
المزيد من تعقيد الصورة عندما تم إفساد أحد
المبلغين عن المخالفات المزعوم لنظام المخزونات
من قبل
جماعات الضغط الخارجية د.  تم طرد ريك برايت مؤخرًا
من منصب رفيع في HHS ،
كما يقول عندما بدأ في الضغط على رؤسائه
لزيادة إنتاج الأقنعة منذ أشهر
، سقطت الصرخات على آذان صماء لم
نزيد من إنتاج الرياضيات ، ولم
يكن هناك أي جهد لفعل
ذلك ما كان يجب أن يحدث  بمجرد ظهور
هذا الوباء ، نعم ، في عام 1999 ،
يشمل المخزون ما قيمته 8 مليارات
دولار من الإمدادات للولايات المتحدة
للانتشار في الكوارث الطبيعية
، الهجمات الإرهابية والأوبئة ، يتم حمايتها في
سرية تامة ، بالضبط ما هو موجود في
المخزن ونحن في منزله مصنفون
عندما توليت هذا الأمر كان صندوقًا فارغًا
ألقى ترامب باللوم على سلفه باراك
أوباما لفشله في تجديد الإمدادات
بعد تفشي إنفلونزا الخنازير في عام 2009 والذي
فشلت إدارة أوباما في القيام به
جزئيًا لأن الكونجرس لم يوافق على
زيادات التمويل للمخزون ، تضمنت
حزمة الإغاثة من فيروس كورونا التي تم تمريرها
مؤخرًا ستة عشر مليار
دولار لتجديد المخزون
الذي نقوم ببناء مخزوننا مرة
أخرى بجنون  لكن الخبراء يقولون إن الأمر سيستغرق
المزيد من التغييرات مثل زيادة
التصنيع المحلي للمعدات الطبية بالنسبة
لنا  لكي نكون مستعدين للوباء القادم ،
نعلم جميعًا أن هذا هو وقت موت
الخسارة ، ومن الصعب
فهم ذلك ، لكن من الواضح أن توني يعرف ما
يعنيه حقًا ، لقد تم استدعائي
الليلة الماضية ،
عزيزي ، يا سيد نبيل ، لقد كانت زوجته
لسنوات عديدة  لقد وافته المنية ، تتمثل مهمة توني في
جمع الجثث وتحريكها ،
فهو لم يكن مشغولاً أبدًا ولم أحصل على
يوم عطلة منذ أن بدأ توني
يعمل في رقعة من الأراضي على طول
الساحل الجنوبي لإنجلترا ،
وأصبحت الوظيفة سباقًا دائمًا على مدار الساعة
يطارد 19 سرًا بلا هوادة
جمع إحصاء الجثث سيدة مسنة من
دار لرعاية المسنين وأحضرها للتو إلى
هنا ، أنتقل الآن مرة أخرى إلى
دار رعاية أخرى حيث توفي شخص آخر ،
لكن الأعداد الهائلة لا
تتحدى فقط أولئك الذين
يحاولون ضمان الكرامة في الموت
يتبع عمال الجنازات هؤلاء في لندن التقاليد الإسلامية ،
إنها عملية محترمة للغاية
غسل وتغليف
كل شخص قبل الدفن ، لكن السلامة
الآن هي الشغل الشاغل لكل جثة.  يجب
التعامل مع y على أنه خطر 19 خفيًا محتملًا ،
ISA ، لقد كان سيدي مدير الجنازة
لمدة 25 عامًا هذا اليوم يجلب لـ ISA
تحديًا مهنيًا وعاطفيًا جديدًا ،
هناك طلب لطفل صغير جدًا
يتوفى ، أحتاج إلى بعض الأوراق
منه وهو طفل ميت صغير
رضيع ووالدة الطفل ، كلاهما ضحيتان من السرقة 19
تم جمعهما مرة واحدة ، وهما يرقدان جنبًا إلى جنب
في الشاحنة ، الطفل في تابوت بحجم الكبار ،
لقد اختبروا كثيرًا أن
عيسى لم يكن مستعدًا لهذا في حياتي ،
إنه تحد صعب إنه  أمر صعب
حتى بالنسبة لي ، إنه صعب للغاية ، إنهم
مؤلمون للغاية في
وقت لاحق ، يرتب عيسى طلبًا خاصًا آخر
وهو يقود سيارته بجوار
مستشفى في لندن حتى يتمكن الموظفون من تكريم
أحدهم وهم يصفقون
لعبد الحفيظ مساعد رعاية إسعاف
آخر  غطت 19 ضحية فقط عدد
قليل منهم يمكنهم حضور جنازته يجب أن
يقفوا منفصلين للصلاة ويمكنهم فقط
الاقتراب من قبره واحدًا تلو الآخر عندما
جاءت سيارة الإسعاف لعبد عائلته
ولم يعرفوا أنها كانت  يخبرني الوقت
الذي ترى فيه كيف يبدو أن تفقد
أخًا بهذه الطريقة ،
إنه يشبه أن تفقد أخًا ، إنه مثل نصفك في
وقت الموت هذا ، معظمنا محصن
من الواقع المروع ، والقليل الملتزمون
يعرفون ما هذه الأرقام الرهيبة  يعني حقًا زيارة
Phil black CNN
London للسويد الآن هو الدخول إلى
أرض غريبة حيث يمكن للناس
التسكع معًا بحثًا عن مأوى من
المطاعم الباردة والحميمة أو تناول مشروب أو
قهوة كانت مزدحمة في جميع
أنحاء الفيروس في المطاعم و  لذا ،
يمكنك التسوق لشراء الأزياء ومستحضرات التجميل
أو حتى السماح لمصفف الشعر بغزو
مساحتك الشخصية التي تلخص
نهج السلطة هنا ، سيكون kovat 19
موجودًا لفترة من الوقت
ويجب على المجتمع أن يجد طريقة للتعايش معها
لذلك لا توجد قوة  الإغلاق بدلاً من ذلك ، التركيز
على المسؤولية الشخصية ، يرجى العمل
من المنزل ، واحتفظ بنفسك في الأماكن العامة ،
فالقاعدة الرسمية في الحانات والمطاعم هي
البقاء بعيدًا عن الآخرين ، لا يوجد
تجمعات لأكثر من 50 شخصًا
لا تزال المدارس المتوسطة والمتوسطة مفتوحة بينما يدرس معظم
طلاب المدارس الثانوية وطلاب الجامعات
في المنزل ، وبما أن Technol هو
عالم الأوبئة بالولاية الذي يقود
السياسات هنا ،
فإنه يدعي النجاح في تسوية
المنحنى والحفاظ على الحالات الخطيرة داخل
قدرة المستشفى ويقول إنه أمر
جيد  تقدر وكالته أن 26 في
المائة من سكان ستوكهولم قد
أصيبوا الآن لأنه من الناحية النظرية
يعني ذلك مزيدًا من المناعة ولكنك تصر على أن
مناعة القطيع لم تكن هدفًا أبدًا ،
لكنها ستساعدنا في تحقيق هدفنا
وهو إبطاء الانتشار
قدر الإمكان.  أنه يمكننا الحفاظ على
صحة جيدة كارين ، لكن بالنسبة لدولة صغيرة ،
تدفع السويد بالفعل تكلفة بشرية كبيرة ،
حيث مات أكثر من 2500 شخص
هنا ، مما أدى إلى
فرض
قيود أكثر صرامة ، وهذا صحيح ، فأنت
تأخذ منهم ، نعم نحن بحاجة
للتحقيق في محاولة لفهم السبب
ونحن نعلم على وجه اليقين أن أحد أسباب
ذلك هو أن لدينا هذا الكم الهائل من
الحالات  في الكتل لدينا ، إنه
اتجاه مزعج يعيش حوالي نصف أولئك الذين ماتوا
هنا في دور رعاية
تعترف الحكومة السويدية بأنهم فشلوا في حماية
كبار
السن ، فالسياسات المفتوحة تحظى بشعبية كبيرة
هنا ولكن هناك غضب أيضًا خاصة
بين أولئك الذين فقدوا  كثيرًا بسبب
الفيروس ، دفنت ميرا جوريا والدها
جوزيف يوم الإثنين ، قالت إنه
سيظل على قيد الحياة مع آخرين كثيرين إذا
اختارت السويد طريقًا مختلفًا ، فهناك
أناس يموتون وهناك إنسان
مثلي مثلك مثل والدي فهم
ليسوا كذلك  مجرد أرقام إحصائية